i think there's a wrinkle to this peter
that goes beyond josh mcdaniels earlier
this week on pftpm miles simmons our
newest arrival at pft and i were talking
about eric b enemy's candidacy with the
texans and miles raised the question of
whether the enemy should have just told
the texans no thanks i don't want to
interview with you because
it seems to be an effort to get back in
the good graces of deshaun watson since
they didn't talk to the enemy during
that bye week when everyone else who had
a vacancy did
and my response was you don't want to
get in the habit of poking your finger
in the eye of a billionaire who owns an
nfl team because the rest of the
billionaires pay attention to that and i
think they resent it if one of them gets
a finger poked in his or her eye and you
become
put in that category of troublemaker for
lack of a better term or somebody who
just doesn't go along with the flow and
there's always plenty of others who do
so
and again regardless of why how
the the details the explanations
it doesn't matter
in the eyes of the broader billionaire
boys club and girls club now
what matters is
you stood up
and told us no and we don't like that i
feel like there's a certain element of
that floating around in all of this
you know maybe mike but i i mean look
the solution for the houston texans
uh starts and ends with one man and
that's eric b enemy um
how far desean watson will take
this
wildcat strike of the houston texans we
don't know no one knows anybody who says
oh that's it he's definitely played his
last snap for the texans i will remind
you of one thing
we are as of this morning
three months and one week away from the
nfl draft
that's nfl draft weekend so
uh unless it's pushed back and roger
goodell's history would say there's no
way we're pushing the stinking draft
back
but unless it's pushed back the houston
texans have three months to solve this
painful chapter in franchise history
will they do it i don't know the best
chance they have is to say to eric b
enemy
uh we want you to be the head coach of
our team and by the way we want you to
salvage the reputation that we don't
have anymore with desean watson
well and eric the enemy is over for six
when it comes to getting hired in this
cycle he's over two in the prior cycles
globally with all of the vacancies the
texans job will be the one if any this
year eric the enemy met with reporters
on thursday in advance of the afc
championship game and was asked about
his desire to take that next step and
become a head coach here he is
here's the thing it's always good to be
mentioned
in in in having an opportunity to pursue
your dreams and obviously yes i do want
to be a head coach but when it's all
said and done with my job is to make
sure everything that we're doing right
now is not to take away from the goals
that we're trying to accomplish the only
thing that matters today we got better
okay today we had an opportunity to make
sure we can take care of situational
football as far as short yardage goal
line in our third down situations so now
it's time for us to go back in and chop
wood wash this tape and get ready for
the next day we want to make sure that
we're getting our guys ready to make
sure they can take care of business on
sunday my own personal business when all
that's time to take care of itself that
will take care of itself
beyond the fact that that little clip i
think strengthens your argument you've
been making for a few years that the
whole process should be delayed until
after the super bowl so you don't have
these coaches who are balancing two
pretty damn big plates at the same time
and they can just focus on the job
they're supposed to do setting that
aside
it
i don't i just don't get it i i don't
get it that you know there's now the
whispers oh he doesn't interview well i
i
play that to play that press conference
i hear him talk like that and i want him
to run my football team if someone would
be dumb enough to let me run one
mike
you know all all the people who uh kind
of ding eric b enemy you know they're
making the choice that they feel at that
time is the best choice for their team
but
to me
the craziest thing about all this is
that in kansas city doug peterson the
offensive coordinator of the team who
didn't call the plays
uh got a job with the philadelphia
eagles ended up winning a super bowl
then two years later matt nagy the
offensive coordinator of the chiefs
got a job with the chicago bears had a
little success and now is struggling but
whatever the story is they got jobs they
were not the full-time play callers they
were
the kitchen cabinet of andy reed that's
what they were
and now you have eric b enemy who's
exactly the same he's done it for three
years this will be the third consecutive
year that the kansas city chiefs have
reached the afc championship game at
home
and you know playing with home field
and i just want someone to tell me just
one person
after hearing
on and off the record from andy reid and
patrick mahomes about how good he is and
what an incredible leader he is
this game for a head coach is still
about
standing in front of the team
and allowing them to lead you making
yourself such a force of nature that
when they leave that meeting room that
they say come on let's all pull on the
rope together that is eric b enemy i'm
just you know it's so it's so weary to
have this argument every year it's
idiotic and if the nfl goes over eric b
enemy again a pox on every owner's house
who's had a coaching vacancy and
a pox on the houston texans for having
it right in their face for having the
only job
open right now the only one
and bypassing the enemy again they
should not do that
especially when there's a damn good
chance that that is the move that could
fix the relationship with their
franchise quarterback who as of now
is at best lukewarm at very best i think
it's it's colder than lukewarm on the
question of whether or not he wants to
stay with the texans you bring in the
enemy and i think deshawn watson may
have a different viewpoint altogether
and
there's something about the enemy peter
that confounds me
and i'm going to use
let me go ahead and give anyone out
there the ten second heads up if you
want to change the channel go ahead and
change it now because i'm going to talk
about colin kaepernick for a second if
you don't like it sorry
when colin kaepernick was in the process
of being shunned
the powers that be
did a very effective job of planting to
willing ears and voices in the media a
whole host of narratives to support the
shunning of colin kaepernick
spurious as they may be
they still did it
with the enemy
the best you hear from anyone as to why
he's not a head coach is this vague
concern about whether he interviews well
which has nothing to do with coaching by
the way you're not hiring somebody to
sit in a room and talk to you for an
hour and a half at a time at the country
club you're hiring someone to coach your
football team but they're not even
trying and i i guess i respect not
trying to put reasons out there more
than
putting out a bunch of bs which they did
with kaepernick
but they're not even trying to fill the
void with an explanation as to why it's
just kind of sitting there
i i have zero explanation for it anymore
mike and uh
you know as i say pox on the nfl's house
if nobody uh if if nobody hires him and
and and i think the one other thing that
that i think is has become very obvious
look i don't know patrick mahomes well
okay yeah i've talked to him quite a few
times over the last three years okay
but
the conversations i've had with him
about eric b enemy are a mixture of
quizzical
and um
sort of telling me
essentially
in a in a strident voice people are so
missing the boat on this guy and
look whatever happens happens life will
go on
but i will not uh be surprised
if there is some form of i don't want to
say organized protest i don't even know
what it would be but i do believe there
will be blow back in a big way if eric b
enemy does not get a job in this hiring
cycle and rightfully so
i can't help but think that at some
level and i try to keep it as basic and
simple as possible and i love to get
into the whole human dynamics because
you can't divorce the human dynamics
from whatever the context is
i just feel like the owners don't like
being told what to do and they feel like
they're being told to hire eric the
enemy and there's a there's a there's a
delicate
balance there and if you're creating the
impression that you're wagging a finger
at these folks they tend to react in a
negative way because no one wags a
finger
at the owner of an nfl team how dare you
tell me what to do i'll do what i damn
well please i'll comply with your rules
and i'll check your boxes but at the end
of the day i'm going to do what i want
to do i feel like that at some level is
the explanation peter what other
explanation could there be why would an
owner deny himself or herself the
opportunity to hire a coach who could do
that thing that all the owners claim
they want to do which is win every super
bowl possible
uh if that is the case mike and i don't
think that's a bad theory but if that is
the case then houston texans season
ticket holders if he does not hire eric
the enemy
should wag their fingers
in the form of
shredding the season ticket renewal
envelope that comes in the mail
and then showing up for the first home
game when there will be 11 people in the
stands
and uh showing up for the first home
game with picket signs
uh
it's it's it's it's gotten beyond absurd
but if the texans don't do the right
thing they can you can talk about well
we're not going to be told what to do
uh
they deserve the ranker that they're
going to receive
yeah i care i can remember when jed york
the ceo of the 49ers said you can't fire
an owner no but you don't have to buy
his products and that eventually will
accomplish the goal so uh we'll see what
happens with the enemy but but i don't
get it peter and you don't get it and i
don't think anybody gets it and we'll
see if the enemy gets the opening in
houston
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports